endlich immer wieder hat er danach
gefragt was ist mit dem motto grafischen
universum ist es bewiesen
es gibt neue beweise das holografische
universum scheint keine spinnerei zu
sein
winter also wirklich nur eine projektion
also wir nur projiziert es gibt neue
hinweise
und das jetzt aktiv zum 26
wirklich ein wenig gespenstisch in den
usa wird der schon länger zielgerichtet
nach dem holografischen universum
geforscht bis jetzt noch ohne ergebnis
werden die wissenschaftler dort fündig
wird es unser weltverständnis auf den
kopf stellen bisher galt ist als höhen
geschwind oder zumindest als eine etwas
abwegige idee
wir sind alle nur dreidimensionale
projektion einer zweidimensionalen
realität wie bei einem fernsehbild gibt
alles dreidimensional aus ist aber in
wirklichkeit nur zweidimensional und das
auch noch verpixelt und genau diese
pixel sollen gefunden werden wenn sie
eine bestimmte größe haben wäre bewiesen
dass unsere welt eine projektion ist und
nicht mit dem kosmologischen
standardmodell übereinstimmt dem lamm
backtag männermodel kurt lambert
britische forscher der university of
southampton haben jetzt im fachmagazin
physical review letters neue
erkenntnisse zur projektion möglichkeit
vorgestellt zitat die von uns getestete
klasse der holographischen modelle für
das frühe universum können mit dem
kosmologischen standardmodell mithalten
zwar sagen die holografischen modelle
andere mache energie fluktuationen
voraus als das lamm pdm modell dennoch
liefern wie ebenfalls eine exzellente
übereinstimmung mit den daten
zitat ende anhand von mit plank
satelliten gesammelten informationen
habe man die kosmische
hintergrundstrahlung versucht mit dem
holografischen modell zu erklären die
idee einer holographischen universums
also dass wir wie in einem 3d für nur
projiziert werden
ist womöglich keine spinnerei sie in der
matrix existieren wir dann nicht
wirklich hier firma woanders auf der
zweidimensionalen hülle des universums
als zweidimensionale werden kann dass
mehr als ein hirngespinst sein
mehr zum thema und viele indizien dafür
dass es wirklich existiert gibt im
ersten video von mir zum monografischen
universum dafür einfach hier klicken
wenn euch das video gefallen hat mir
auch jeden fall einen daumen nach oben
da und abonniert ist kostenlos dafür
hier klicken
müller und auf die glocke klicken
wenn ich wirklich kein video mehr und
lass mir eure meinung zum holografischen
universum da ist das kann man sich das
überhaupt vorstellen
naja wird dann bleibt dran sagt euch
vielleicht eine 3d projektion